[Musique]
et
miss énergie c'est son nom de scène mais
d'énergie alf apps et oulaï va bientôt
en manquer la chanteuse lyonnaise
originaire du congo subi de plein fouet
la crise sanitaire
comme beaucoup de ses confrères et
consoeurs moins médiatisé le premier
confinement a eu raison de sa tournée en
france depuis ni concert ni scène ni
public
c'est compliqué parce que j'ai même
paris je suis à voir mon intermittence
j'étais un peu loin donc j'ai même pas
eu le le minimum des dates qu'il fallait
des transports pour que le gouvernement
puisse se tenir et aux plus de cachet
plus de statut d'intermittent
conséquence directe l'année blanche
ristournes financière promise par le
gouvernement lui est passé sous le nez
ça c'est vraiment le côté matériel le
côté matériel qui est important au bien
entendu mais pour moi même si
aujourd'hui on arrivait comme donné
alpha p thomas était né des millions des
voix là tout de suite oui ça va régler
plein de problèmes mais il y aura 80% de
mon âme de mon être qui sera toujours
perdu parce que moi il me faut il faut
absolument que ce soit sur scène ce
premier confinement n'entame pas pour
autant son moral en avril dernier chaque
samedi alfa multiplie les concerts en
live sur facebook
son seul contact avec le public le
moment aussi de rester dans ce partage
est là l'énergie avec les publics avec
les personnes 4 si le projet est là bien
entendu ce que j'aimerais c'est que les
choses puissent revenir en normal
en tout cas la norme que nous
connaissons qui est d'être sur scène et
d'être en contact avec le public
parce que vraiment ça manque quand ça
manque ce côté là les tâches des règles
son rêve désormais gratter de nouveau
sur scène sa guitare fétiche
il ya des moments où je me dis il faut
absolument que ça reprenne
parce que ces guitares à elle me manque
c'est c'est ma préférée c'est c'est my
lave et que la pandémie fasse évoluer la
considération pour le monde de la
culture et j'espère j'espère que quand
ça va reprendre
on les cultures et tout ça on pourront
continuer à voir les aides ou des
artistes indépendants ou des gens comme
moi qui ont pas pu avoir des
intermittences
du coup on concède il a quand même dans
ce magasin plein d'albums en moi depuis
un an
alpha profit de cet isolement pour
composer de nouvelles chansons
[Musique]
elle prépare un single avec un nouveau
morceau swahili sur la pandémie dans ce
studio où elle enfile de nouveau son
costume de scène 1 et en attendant de
pouvoir y remonter
[Musique]